hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested it's from the
american cup from the champions bracket
fabiano corona versus lavon arenan i
hope you guys are having an excellent
sunday and i hope this game improves it
even just um by a little bit but i'm
sure you guys will be very happy about
this one it's a game uh that really
shows how even a very very slight lapse
in judgment can result in a completely
unplayable position and by completely
unplayable i mean a completely
unplayable position when you face a
super grandmaster like these two here
are facing each other
so without further ado let's check it
out uh fabi has the white pieces and he
opens with c4 he opens with the english
opening knight to f6 we have knight to
c3 and e5 now the two knights variation
and that often uh transposes into the
four knights variation of the english
with g3 and now most popular here is d5
also developing the bishop is very
popular but levon goes knight to d4 it's
a very tricky line
uh but of course these um top players
know exactly what uh what it's all about
uh capturing the e5 pawn is not uh for
free of course after queen to e7 there's
a not a very good retreat square for
tonight if you move it back you you just
get smothered mated uh and uh well yeah
after something like queen e7 you're
gonna have to play f4 and you can see
that after d6 white's position is
already looking uh not so spectacular so
after this knight to d4 idea fabi just
continues developing bishop g2 and we
have a trade knight captures bishop
captures now this bishop is not
optimally placed later on maybe it can
even be challenged with a move like e4
so bishop to c5 and now d3 we have
castles by levon and castles by fabi and
you can see how uh well uh fabi's
bishops are for example placed the dark
square bishop uh has this beautiful
diagonal as fabi's pawns are placed on
light squares and this bishop has been
fee and carrot so yeah it doesn't mind
that the pawns are on light squares as
you will be using your uh bishop along
this diagonal and uh it's a known
position it has been reached before uh
for example even in 1976 mikkeltel had
the position against walter brown uh
where rook the e8 was played at that
game ended in a very very quick draw in
some 14 moves so that's very weird tal
drawing in 14 moves uh it's something
that we will definitely investigate at
one point but here levon plays a5 and it
is now as of move eight that we have a
completely new game and now what does
this a5 move do well of course it
prevents white from pushing b4 and that
in itself is a small victory for black
so now let's see how fabian continues
bishop back to g2 it's not a race or
anything there's nothing that needs to
happen right away so you do have time to
improve your position and bishop does
definitely belong on g2 at some point if
d6 this bishop can come to h3 uh so it's
uh uh a lot safer here uh we have c6 now
preparing the strike with d5 bishop to
d2 and uh pawn to d6 still waiting with
the d5 breakthrough uh a3 now uh with
some possibilities of maybe attacking
the bishop and then executing b4 bishop
to e6 and now queen to c2 so a
continuing development connecting the
rooks
uh h6 and now knight to a4 going after
the bishop so bishop to a7 and now well
now you could play b4 it's definitely a
good idea but here fabi plays c5 it's a
very
strong positional idea it completely
locks out the dark square bishop part of
the game plus if black captures it will
weaken the e5 pawn as nothing is
defending it so uh levon decides that he
does not want his bishop to be out of
the game so he trades here knight pawn
captures knight captures bishop captures
and the queen captures on c5
attacking the e5 pawn and levon defense
by playing bishop to d5 so now the queen
can't capture also you are hoping that
white will capture on d5 and then
you will uh well trade it down a little
bit but also you can get your pieces
into the game so here fab declines the
trade he plays f3 he says okay i'm gonna
push e4 at some point and when i play e4
the bishop will move and then i might
win the uh the e5 pawn so here we have
a4 eleven not worried about this and you
will see why uh favi plays e4 now
challenges the bishop on d5 but first
knight to d7 we do not want the queen
attacking our pawn so the queen has to
go back queen to e3 ending now only now
bishop to b3 so for the moment the pawn
is nicely defended we have f4 by fabi
now if the pawn captures then
uh you will be able to advance your
backwards d3 pawn to d4 and your
position will improve drastically and
this is the moment where uh levon really
has to figure out how to continue
playing this and it's not an easy uh
decision in the game levon played queen
to b6 offering a queen trade uh but as
you'll see this is not the the best way
to go about the position the best way is
to play c5
because we really want to prevent this
pawn from coming to d4 and this pawn
staying on d3 means that it will remain
a target forever and we're going to be
able to pile up on it and it doesn't
matter even if we
temporarily go down in material upon uh
we will always be able to pick up this
d3 pawn and it's very very hard for
uh white uh
to continue playing this position so c5
is definitely the key idea here but
levon played queen to b6 and now you
will see how uh how much levon will
struggle to put the pawn uh
back to c5 because the pawn really does
belong on c5 you're gonna play b6 and
then you're going to remaneuver the
knight maybe you can play the knight
here knight here knight here and then
knight to d4 uh it's a really really
nice position for for black but here
queen to b6 was played and now fabi
captures the queen knight captures and
now rook 8 the c1 and now of course the
c5 uh is no longer an option the rook uh
controls that plus also you are
preparing to even just double up on the
c file you can put more pressure on this
pawn the bishop is coming to c3 so at
some point black will either have to
give up the pawn here or play uh e
captures an f4 and that's something you
don't want to do so rook after d8
attacking the d3 pawn but now rook f3
there is a way to defend the d3 pawn now
and that's going to be a problem for
black so knight to d7 adding a defender
to the pawn now bishop to h3 saying okay
if you play c5 now i can just eliminate
the defender and then pick up the c5
pawn so you can see uh the
move levon could have played a long time
ago now he is very very much struggling
to to play it so here we have bishop to
e6
defending against this bishop here we
have a captures captures and now king to
f2
we have c5 finally the move has been
played but now it is not as as strong in
black's position is not um so powerful
if you just put your pawn on b6 and c5
right away uh you could have played many
many other useful moves so here king e2
b6 uh and now bishop to c3 putting more
pressure on this e5 square and if you
capture here we're gonna capture here
and now that's uh well that's not the
way to play chess the g7 pawn will come
under attack and this will be just
immense pressure from white so instead
after bishop to c3 we have rook eight to
c8 and now rook f back to f1
uh preparing to at uh well
you can either bring the rook to d1 or
as in the game as uh levon shifted the
rook to f8 now just king to e3
rook to c7 and now f captures on e5 so
we finally capture this pawn this
doubles our e pawn uh but uh we we're
still up upon and being up upon can be
very very meaningful in these uh former
2800 clashes so here rook captures an f1
rook captures on f1 and not knight to b8
the knight is now hoping to come to c6
into d4 and uh it's a well it's a very
tricky position it's a very complicated
end game it's a bishop against the
knight but uh fabi shows that if you
know your stuff uh there's nothing
complicated about this position so feel
free to pause the video and uh you know
do what fabi does best while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
brilliant idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course pawn to d4 that's right we do not
want to see this knight on c6
controlling the d4 square and now we are
even threatening d5 and that's going to
be too much for black to handle so here
we have to capture c captures on d4
bishop captures and now how do you play
this okay the b6 pawn is hanging we
could play something like pawn to b5 but
then we bring our bishop back to c3 and
now you can no longer
activate your rook with a powerful rook
to c2 idea so instead after bishop
captures on d4
levon plays rook the c2 now attacking
the h2 pawn and now rook to d1 uh fabi
will of course put the bishop on c3 he
will play rook to d6 go after the pawns
here and he says my rook is much faster
than your rook so knight to c6 hoping
that uh
fabi captures on on b6 so levon can
capture on e5 but just bishop back to c3
and you can see how here the bishop is
beautifully controlling the knight so
the knight really has no squares here uh
and even if you shift the knight over to
e7 still the this pawn is controlling
both of these squares so not a lot of
good squares for this knight even if you
bring it all the way to g6 still the g3
pawn uh prevents the knight from going
anywhere so the the knight really is uh
a bad piece here the bishop is much much
better so rook captures an h2 winning
the pawn back but now rook to d2 attack
rook to d6 attacks the knight and all of
the pawns on the sixth rank uh knight to
a5 and now uh we just play king to f3
and i know what you guys are thinking
why
why in the world would we play king to
f3 when we can just grab this e6 pawn
and create uh our own past e pawn the
problem is if rook captures an e6 king
f7 traps the rook that's why of course
you can see that all of these squares
are covered now by the king uh this is
covered by the knight and if of course
you play king the rook to d6 then of
course knight c4 uh forks the king and
rook and now black wins the game
so that's why we're going to move the
king king to f3 no forks are now
possible king f7 defending the e6 pawn
but now we capture on b6 and also we add
another defender to the b2 pawn knights
the c4 attacking the rook here rugby 7
check and now
okay you might go back to defended the
pawn uh but after king jesus king j8 you
are not getting that king back into the
game it would be very hard to even
imagine that king going into the game so
levon decides to bring the king into the
game actively but this also includes
giving up the g7 pawn so here fabi
captures it uh knight captures on b2 as
now the rook no longer guards the b2
square and not bishop to b4 uh preparing
rookie 7 check this will uh
eliminate the e6 pawn as well so king d8
now comes rook to e7 and not knight to
c4 we have rook captures on e6 and now
pawn to h5
bishop to d6 now comes pawn to h4 we
have rook to g6 and now rook to h3
piling up on the g3 pawn uh but it
doesn't really matter rook g8 check king
d7 rook g7 check king to e8 and now rook
the c7 check attacking the knight and uh
here the point is uh
there there's really not much you can do
with black rook captures on g3 check was
played king f4 and now your knight is
still hanging so uh what do you play if
you play something like knight to d to
hope to maybe do some sort of a
checkmating pattern or even maybe just a
a stalemate or something after e6 it's
just over all of the squares are
controlled here this is the thread of
checkmate and you are getting checkmated
very soon for example king the eight
seven check you have to go back rook c h
at king f7 and now this will of course
uh uh result or even just this i mean
it's a game over in a few moves so after
king to f4 knight captures and d6 was
played eliminating this bishop but this
also means that fabi now gets to
undouble his pawns so e captures on d6
and now uh after rook captures on a3
king to f5 was played rook to g3 and
here just e5 uh andy was in this
position uh on move uh 53 that levon
aaron resigned the game and a beautiful
beautiful victory for fabiana corona
to improve everyone's sunday
so here the material is now completely
equal and both players have two pass
pawns however uh fabi's passpons are
just much much too strong uh to give you
an example as i know you guys enjoy
examples for example h3 e6 and that's it
all of the squares are now being covered
in front of the white king we're just
gonna check made the black king
the black king and now after king to d8
it's pretty much the same idea king to
e8 check king moves and now e8 queen and
you are getting checkmated very quickly
king g7 queen e7 checking h6 and rook to
h8 will be uh checkmate so of course
levon knows this and after e5 uh he
resigned in the game as he's pretty much
gonna move uh this pawn only one square
and that's it there's not nowhere to go
from there so it's a brilliant brilliant
game and played on the absolute top
level that just shows you how uh how
incredible uh for example in in this
position where fabi uh played this f4
move uh how queen the b6 seems like a
perfectly good idea but it it is exactly
the opposite of a good idea because you
want your pawns on b6 and c5 and this
knight has to remaneuver itself to d4
and by playing queen to b6 this is the
exact opposite of of that plan so
it's uh
a tough break but uh
i mean uh chess is chess is brutal like
this i mean it looks it looks perfectly
fine you you trade the queens and then i
mean it doesn't look like white has
anything even if white captures an e5 is
going to be a double pawn that's uh
how levon went about it
but
i mean this was the only plan and the
fabi was just on top of the game for the
uh every every move after this uh queen
to b6 idea
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh always uh when your
opponent has a backwards pawn like this
d3 pawn that cannot go forward limiting
it even further makes it a a permanent
target for forever and you will i mean
it will be enough to create many many
chances and not lose the game uh
hopefully uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and that it
improved your sunday at least uh a
little bit uh i would i would like to
thank uh robert taratun uh michael
mcconnell nagarjuna sureshka and paul
hindermund for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day